you want to try and escape
i don't know just on the bottom not drop
in oh yeah dude i'll skate straight
across the bottom is there like a like
uh
yeah
i can already tell the breeze
oh of swords like a
he wants a harness yeah i want to give
on a horse yeah
i just wait there's a horse are you
skating i just need some help brother
you know yeah we'll give you hell okay
i'm not bringing a [ __ ] harness for
you you can hold my my hand if you want
whoa hold on bro what it's not like that
i'm saying my dick my hand two different
things yeah but i'll wear a glove if it
makes it more hair dryer yeah but you'll
put the glove on your dick i know you
i know it's a gateway